Because interviewing Barbara Yanna.
You got it on the truck.
They must be from the truck out of respect.
Who has it?
They give you?
Sometimes I'm walking to the cage and they give me the thing in my ear.
Winner and loser.
Yeah.
Oh really?
Every now and then man.
Yeah.
Did David approach you to work for ESPN or not?
We just get,
it was like no.
We know where he's not,
not interested,
but I don't feel like I would take this for zero money over being in Phoenix
right now,
although I would want to see those fights live and I'd love to call those fights
like I'm good with 10 a year.
That's what I like.
I like 10 a year.
But did they coach you?
They didn't even want to,
nope.
10 10 a year.
10 years.
What?
I like once a month.
10 shows,
10 a year.
What's a month dude?
Once a month.
What?
Just the paper?
Two months.
Two months off.
Once a month.
Listen man,
I was thinking that I was on my way out.
I was really thinking I was on my way out,
but I still love it and I love it way more now because I don't have to do it as
much,
and I love it way more now because we do this because we can do all this shit
talking and have fun and be silly.